daos fx igual a 2 x 3 / x g de menos 1
igual a 3 y g prima de menos 1 igual a
menos 2 cuál es la pendiente de la
tangente de la curva efe en el punto
donde x es igual a menos 1 así que la
manera en la que podemos resolver este
problema es simplemente sacar la
derivada de esta función efe y luego
evaluarla en x igual a menos 1 y por la
manera en la que definieron a efe
es decir observa la definición de esta
función podemos ver que es un cociente
de dos funciones
así que si nosotros queremos sacar su
derivada podrán decir bien tal vez aquí
la regla del cociente es importante y
podríamos usarla y si es así te daré mi
aprobación la regla del cociente podría
ser muy útil en caso de que la sepan
pero si no la saben o la han olvidado la
pueden obtener fácilmente utilizando la
red del producto y la regla de la cadena
esta es una forma muy fácil de sacar la
regla del cociente pero supongamos que
te la sabes bien así que permíteme
simple
enunciar la regla del cociente aquí
mismo si quiero encontrar la derivada de
esta función es más déjame escribirla
primero tengo que fx
efe de x
es la función 2 x 3 ok esto a su vez es
tan / gtx ok y si ahora quiero encontrar
f prima de x lo voy a poner con este
color f prima de x utilizando la regla
del cociente va a ser igual a quien
bueno si tienes una función definida
como una función en el numerador entre
una función en el denominador bueno
podemos decir que su derivada primero va
a ser la derivada de la función del
número 2
déjame ponerle un nombre voy a suponer
que esta función de aquí está de aquí le
voy a poner el nombre de hdx voy a
suponer que es h de x entonces me
quedaría la derivada la derivada con
respecto a x claro esta de esta función
a hdx
y a esta función la vamos a multiplicar
por la función de abajo tal cual está
déjame ponerla con este color gtx lo voy
a trabajar con este color entonces a
esto habrá que multiplicarlo por gd x
y a esto habrá que quitarle a esto le
tenemos que quitar la derivada de la
función de abajo déjame escribirlo la
derivada con respecto a x de gd x de que
es de x ok
esto a su vez multiplicado por la
función que tenemos arriba que acabamos
de decir acabamos de bautizar con el
nombre de htx ok
y todo esto hay que dividirlo todo esto
hay que dividirlo entre la función que
tenemos abajo elevada al cuadrado es
decir
de equis
esta función elevada a su vez al
cuadrado elevada al cuadrado y bueno
claro que podemos usar situaciones
diferentes para la derivada de g con
respecto a x
en lugar de esto podríamos haber escrito
que prima de x es exactamente lo mismo o
aquí en lugar de la derivada de h con
respecto a x podremos haber puesto
simplemente h prima de x es lo mismo
poner esta anotación esta anotación o
esta anotación muy bien ahora lo que
nosotros queríamos encontrar es la
derivada pero evaluada en un punto en el
punto x igual a menos 1 y seguramente te
preguntas bueno como lo evalúa pero es
muy simple como queremos encontrar la
pendiente de la recta tangente a la
curva efe en el punto donde x es igual a
menos 1 esencialmente lo que necesitamos
encontrar es la derivada evaluada en
menos 1 es decir
efe
prima de menos 1 que por cierto esta va
a ser la pendiente que buscamos y si
nosotros queremos evaluar estos menos 1
esto va a ser exactamente igual que
escribir h prima de menos 1 h prima de
este valor de menos 1 ok esto que a su
vez multiplica a g de menos 1 recuerda
estamos evaluando en este valor de menos
17 menos 1 ok ya esto quitarle la
derivada de la función g evaluada en
menos 1 la derivada de la función g
evaluada en menos 1 ya esto
multiplicarlo por la función h evaluada
en menos uno por la función h evaluada
en menos 1 y todo esto dividirlo y a
todo esto dividirlo entre la función g
evaluada en el punto menos uno que de
menos uno esto elevado a su vez al
cuadrado ok ahora falta saber cuánto es
hd menos 1 h prima de menos 1 me quede
menos 1 ig prima de menos 1 pero lo
bueno es que aquí nos dan algunos
valores nos dicen que quede menos uno es
igual a tres así que eso lo voy a
utilizar en lugar de gt menos uno voy a
poner tres aquí en lugar de que de menos
uno voy a poner el valor de tres y bien
por aquí en lugar de g de menos uno voy
a poner también el valor de tres y por
otra parte me dicen que g prima de menos
uno es igual a menos dos que prima de
menos uno es igual a menos dos así que
aquí donde tengo que primera 2-1 voy a
poner menos 2 va a ser más fácil tener
aquí el valor de menos 2 muy bien ahora
la pregunta es cuánto valen hd menos 1 y
h prima de menos 1 bueno para eso vamos
a utilizar la función hd
es que si recuerdas la definimos como la
función del número dos si tengo que hdx
déjame escribirlo aquí hdx la definimos
como 2 x + 3 ok cuánto vale la derivada
de esta función
bueno h prima de x va a ser la derivada
de 2 x 3 y eso es muy fácil la derivada
de 2x bueno eso es simplemente 2 y la
derivada de una constante se va hasta
que me quedan simplemente 2 y si yo
quiero saber cuánto vale h de menos uno
bueno simplemente tengo que evaluar esta
función de menos uno me quedaría 2 x
menos 1 lo cual es menos 2 + 3
3 entonces esto es simplemente uno ok
en lugar de hd menos 1 voy a escribir 1
aquí lo tengo en lugar de hd menos 1 voy
a escribir simplemente 1 y si yo quiero
saber cuánto vale la función h prima de
x pero evaluada en menos 1 h prima de
menos 1 esto va a ser igual a la
derivada evaluada al menos 1 pero aquí
no tenemos ninguna xy tenemos una
constante la constante 2 así que esto va
a ser igual a 2 y ya lo puedo poner aquí
en lugar de h prima de menos 1 voy a
escribir simplemente 2 y qué creés
ya tenemos cada uno de los valores de
hxd h prima de x deje de x y deje prima
de x evaluados en menos 1 por lo tanto
ya puedo reducir un poco toda esta
expresión voy a decir que f prima de
menos 1 va a ser simplemente dos por
tres lo cual es
- al menos dos por uno lo cual es más
dos más dos menos por menos es más dos
por unos dos está dividido entre tres
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 9 es
decir que esto va a ser igual a 8
novenos que es justo lo que me estaban
preguntando la pendiente que nosotros
buscábamos es igual a la derivada
evaluada en el punto menos 1 que
nosotros ya sabemos que es igual a 8
novenos a ocho novenas y aquí lo tiene
al principio parece un poco intimidante
pero solo piensen que si aplicamos
primero la regla del cociente porque
tenemos una función definida como el
cociente de dos funciones puedo
encontrar así la derivada de esta
función fx y si después evaluamos todos
en menos uno de una manera muy sencilla
podemos encontrar los valores de g de
menos 1
que prima de menos 1 hd menos 1 y este
primera menos uno y después simplemente
tuvimos que trabajar un poco con estos
valores y así obtener el resultado que
nosotros buscábamos así que espero que
esto lo encuentres útil